تتحدث عن وضع العمل على مواقع التواصل
سترحل تنتقد
سياستين
بينك وبين زملائك سترحل لا تتحمل العمل
لفتره طويله ايضا اجمع اشياءك وغادر هذه
اداره الماسك التي يتبعها منذ استحوا به
على تويتر وتسببت باحساس بان ايام الموقع
معدوده
وحتى انا المستخدمين اطلقوا هاشتاج تويتر
ارقد بسلام منصه في التدوينكو او العصفور
الاصفر منافس تويتر في الهند تصطاد في
الماء العكر وتقول انها ستعين موظفات
تويتر مفصلين لتطوير خدماتها والايمانها
برعايه الموهوبين لا قمهم لكن موظف في
تويتر مفصولين قد استخدمونا خبراتهم ضد
ماسك
السوشيال ميديا فقط
لذلك لابد ان نطرح السؤال الذي طرحه
مراقبون على امتداد هذا العام هل يتسبب
غرور الى الماسك المفترض بهذه الازمه
اجاباتنا مع لميس
تويتر يحتضر نحن نشهد نهايه احد اهم افضل
من الصوت التواصل بسبب غرور الى الماسك
واعجابه بذاته وقراراته المندفعه هكذا يرى
كثيرون من منتقدين ماسك الغرور بجانب
الاداره المنفرده سبب موجه من عدم
الاستقرار داخل منصه سواء على مستوى
الاداره داخليه او من ناحيتي تجربه
المستخدم الى الماسك بصراحه اكثر من نصف
موظفي تويتر بعد استحواذيه على الشركه في
اكتوبر الماضي ويقول ان الفتره المقبله
اصعب وحاليا يخير الموظفين الناجين من
مجزره الاقالات بين العمل لفترات طويله هو
تحت ضغط شديد او الرحيل
اعترض على خطته ورفض ظروف العمل المرعبه
التي تنتظرهم من اجل تصميم نسخه جديده
تماما من تويتر تويتر
ضبابيه التي يقال انه لم يشاركها حتى معلم
المهندسين الرئيسيين ورؤوس الحرب في
الشركه والمئات قدموا لقيتهم بالفعل
يخسر ماسك الموظفين مفصولين او يسخر منهم
علنا على حسابه يعتذر عن فصل العباقره
ويقول ان مواهبهم ستكون مفيده في مكان اخر
لكنه في نفس الوقت يفتح باب التوظيف
لاضافه دماء جديده لكن الموظفين الاكثفاء
مترددون فمن يريد الابحار على سفينه تغرق
[موسيقى]
طيب من جد طويل اعمال
يسعد صباحك دائما اهلا بك معنا
الغرور الى الماسك ثقته الزائده حبه للانا
كانت سببا في الازمه المتفقه على تويتر
اليوم
يعني هتتفاجا من رديه خلينا ناخذ الامر
على جانبين جانب خساره الموظفين ايش اثرها
على الشركات وجانب هل هذا الموضوع ينطبق
على اله الناس ولا لا انا عن نفسي راي شخص
يقول لك بعدين هتعرف ليه الشركه التي تفقد
موظف جونيور يعني مبتدا تخسر من سته الى
تسعه اضعافرك او 9 مرات ليش لانهم سووا
اعلانات رواتب الموظفوا معلقه تكلفه
التدريب والمكان غير انه ممكن يسبب حاجتين
ثانيه الموظف الصغير يسموها كثير بلاس
الخوف من خسران الوظيفه اللي بيبدا ينتشر
مع باقي الموظفين ويبدا انتاجياتهم
والحاجه الثانيه انه ممكن يسيء يعني
هذه الحاجه ثاني اللي ممكن تضرك في الجونه
السينير اللي هو اللي على مرتبه مدير ممكن
يخسرك فريق عمل لانه الناس اترك الوظائف
بسبب مدير سيئه وتروح للوظيفه بسبب مدير
جيد فاذا انا عندي مدير جيد هاروح معه الى
مكان ثاني ممكن يكون منافس اما الاجزاء
هتلز الناس التنفيذيه زي ما صار مصري
بتسلا رئيس المصممين الخاص بتسلا خرج وبدا
لوسيب وجاب صندوق الاستثمارات السعوديه
من اكبر الشركات
والان اصيد الانسان هذه الثلاثاء المراحل
هل ينطبق الموضوع هذا معيار الناس راي
شخصي نعم ولا يعني قد يتاثر نوعا ما
بموضوع سمعه خروج الموظفين وخوف وفله
الانتاجيه في هذه المرحله بس عنق الزجاجه
ليش قالوا الناس جاب الحوض معه هو هو حب
الشغل والان احنا في العربيه وفي جميع
القنوات التلفزيونيه الكل يتكلم عنه حتى
لو كانت الدعايه سلبيه في النهايه الان
شوفي كميه التفاعل على تويتر واللي ما
حصلت منذ بدا تويتر في من نشاتها ما وصلت
تفاعل بهذا العدد الحسن العدد المصوتين
على ترامب كل ساعه مليون بني ادم 15 سنه
انطلاقا من هذا الموقف هل في ايجابيات
احنا ما بنعرفها اتخذها ترامب مش ترامب
الى مصر اتخذها في استراتيجته في التعامل
مع الموظفين يعني كمدير
طبعا ليش في نقطه هامه غير عن المدير
قالوا الناس بيستخدم حاجه اسمها
وارجع ابنيه بطريقه مختلفه بدل ما ابدا
حاجه من جديد اقول تويتر
قيمتها السوقيه 22 فدافع 44 ضعف القيمه
السوقيه المهم الفرار هذا ما هو انسان هذا
الرجل في العالم فما هو جاي من فراغ حتى
البطاريات والابتكرات حقته كان يعيدها
لاساها ويرجع يصنع منها عراب
سي ا بي تو سي ايش يعني بي تو سي وبي توبي
بي تو بي يعني انا شركه جالسه اقدم لك
خدمات مجانيه للمستهلكين مقابل اني انا
اروح اسوي شراكات مع المعلنين ودخلي كله
بسمع المعلمين الون ماسك اصلا يروح يتعامل
مع الكستناز يسموها بزنس تو كاس تومه بزنس
تو بيزنس من شركه بيزنس من شركه الى
العملاء مباشره
سبيس اكس الناس اللي جلسه يتريقوا عليه
ويقولوا له انه حتى
اكثر من مليار
باكثر اكثر من مليار دولار عقد واحدثه
الفكره فين انه هذه الفكره اللي جاء فيها
جبل حوض يعني انا جاي اعيد القاعده تماما
الثمانيه دولار هذه لو جات يعني عندنا 200
مليون مثلا مشترك في تويتر لو واحد% منهم
يعني 2 مليون بني ادم اشتركوا بثمانيه
مليون دولار 16 مليون في الشهر اضربيها في
على مدار السنه غير الاشياء الثانيه اللي
جالس يجيبها خلى مين خلي المبرمجين وانت
تقول لي عندك علاقات عامه وعندك موسيقينا
موسى وكيل ما يعرفوا يجيبوا لي اعلانات
الان اذا تركنا الموضوع التقني ورحنا
للشخصيه هل بشكل عام الغرور يقتل صاحبه هل
هناك اخطاء قد يرتكبها المدير التنفيذي
لشركه ما عليه ان يتراجع وان يعترف بخطئه
مثلا
طبعا احنا بنقول هذه القرارات الهوجاء
اللي بدون دراسه بدون تفكير ممكن تنهي
شركات وشفنا شركات كبرى انتهت بسبب هذا
الموضوع كودا كانت اكبر من اكبر شركات
العالم انتهت تماما بانها ما تطورت مع
تكنولوجيا نوكيا وغيرها لكن ارجع اقول لك
الو الماسك مو مبرمج والحمله اللي سايره
فيها جزء كبير سياسي لانه هو يعني ما الي
الجمهوريين والقنوات اللي جلسه تطلع انه
نهايه تويتر وكل المعلومات السلبيه عنه هي
قنوات تابعه للديمقراطيين بتدعمهم فكثير
من التناقل والاشياء السلبيه حتى لما قال
على موضوع اوكرانيا انه ممكن يوقف الموضوع
الحرب على ستار لينك السعوديه
كبيره فالان عندنا جانب سياسي وجانب شخصي
وان هو انسان عارف ما جاء يدفع ضعف قيمه
السوق همم او قيمه السوقيه للشركه الا هو
عنده فكره ثانيه
من المتابعين والان جالس يوصل انه بينقل
مباريات كاس العالم بيوصل للمتابعين اكثر
من الشركات لانه في مجموعات ضغط سياسيه
واعلاميه من الشركات بتضغط عليه لكن من
واقع يعني دراستنا لموضوع شخصيه اردن ماسك
ممكن يغامر بكل شيء مقابل انه تنجح فكره
ويشوفها واقع هذا اللي صار معه في سبيس
اكس هذا الي صار معه كان على شفا الابلاس
ودائما يطلع منها ويكون ناجح وبيحقق
نجاحات مبهره وهو مبسوط حتى على فكره حتى
بالدعايه السلبيه لما الناس تتكلم عنه لما
طلعوا شابين وضحكوا على الاعلام وسووا
نفسهم موظفين انهم خرجوا من الوظيفه
وطلعوا بيعملوا مقلب في وسائل الاعلام
جابهم وساووا معهم دعايه بيقول لهم رجعنا
الموظفين مره ثانيه وانا عرفت هو جالس
يضحك بس بيسخر حتى من الموقف باكمله وجالس
يقول لهم شكرا كل اللي قلته زاد عدد
المتابعين فهي القرارات الهجاء اكيد تخسر
اي انسان ممكن منصبه وظيفته او شركه
المستقبل زي ما قلنا ايام ال- همم كيف همم
انهارت الان وصار لها مشاكل ارجع اقول لك
حتى تتذكري انه قالوا ناس هيرجع بافكار
ابداعيه مع فريق برمجه وجالس يستقبل ناس
وفعلا انا لو مكانه احد يجي ينتقد سياسي
مباشره وينشر سلبيه داخل المكان ما احتاجه
لو معك افضل شهاده ما يحتاج بيئه سلبيه
ابغى ناس تؤمن بفكرتي وتكون معايا عشان
نحقق الانجاز الرائع ان شاء الله ما يخذلك
ماسك اعتراض مال رب عقليته المتهوره
والمغامره شكرا اعتراض تطوير العمل